it's Irish I mean just how bad are
things I mean I was looking at some of
the stats that you had that I think in
Japan which will come to properly just a
three percent of board members are women
and in career even less less than three
percent yep so hong kong by comparison
is 11.1 percent and is improving slowly
glacially but it is improving so why
that's what you've got to address isn't
it and then how to deal with it okay so
firstly there's a global problem which
is that boards mostly men don't see this
as a problem in Hong Kong it's much more
i think prevalent and so firstly you've
got to deal with with the primary issue
of getting boards to recognize that
gender diversity board diversity group
think is is something they need to
address so you know how do we do that we
need to get boards to use external
forces external search firms to help
them appoint new directors and at
present they don't they use their
friends and family which perpetuates the
problem and I think women need to become
more visible well and yeah the good
reason is a good business case as I
mentioned in an introduction to you to
actually have women on the board
McKinsey catalyst Blackrock all have
done huge studies for the last 10 years
and each study comes out and reinforces
the previous one which is that companies
make more returns better rewards
long-term success for their stakeholders
why is that the case I think where you
have boards made up of only one gender
or only one group of people groupthink
becomes a problem and boards need a
degree of tension the non execs need to
hold the executives to boot took 22 to
be responsible for their actions maybe
that's an issue at Volkswagen for
example this group think an issue there
so you need to have a degree of tension
of board question now is you know if you
only have one in nine women on board
you don't have enough diversity you
don't have enough individuals
challenging the status quo but you know
that also that you know you could argue
that if this is as you truly
meritocratic then you've got to get
women and maybe women aren't cutting it
could be the devil's advocate argument
it could be if that was the case if you
had lots of women churning on boards
because they weren't lasting but they're
not getting two boards so it's not just
a board issue it's also the pipeline
underneath the board so that baby was a
ceiling underneath underneath underneath
there's a ceiling underneath the ceiling
yeah there's a leaking pipe line you
know when you get to different countries
but 30 35 women have children they don't
return to the workplace we've got to
find ways to getting more women to
return and women not to leave to do
other other things I think you're just
getting out of Japan as promised said
now that would hinder ave sees the
problem but that's also pointed anted
the fact that they have this said
obviously this whole issue with an aging
population to how does he get women
omics going Chuckie so they've just
passed a law whether it's good Laurent I
don't know but they've passed a law that
says that all companies or public
companies in Japan have to declare their
gender balance if they lie there'll be a
penalty but if they go from zero to zero
there is no penalty for that either so
it's quite a soft law see it pointless
well I think the point is to actually
raise it as an awareness item the more
companies boards have to now start to
report items suddenly they start to
bring the item into their boardroom
conversation which is how are we doing
our hundred doing better than toshiba
you know company X company why doing
better and so on and I think what we saw
in the UK with the thirty percent club
they used peer pressure to increase the
number of women on boards from Hong
Kong's current level of eleven percent
to now twenty five percent and the run
rate is more than thirty percent of new
appointments are women but it all
started with peer pressure our Bay is
doing the same thing he's using peer
pressure to see if you can raise the the
interest level and the decision
points